all right i think that covers everybody
so let's move on i am the aqua king oh
for god's sake
every creature of the sea obeys me my
power
is virtually
limitless
apparently not your power of speech
i was supposed to work with madonna and
uh i went over a house and we were
joking about the tesla sky video and i
told her i used pamela anderson because
i grew up on her she helped you know
make me
a man
looked like my dad was getting a little
jealous i was like no no i used to jack
off to you too
went to ucla med school shout out tran
you completely hope that's her last name
that's her last name relax espn how dare
you
great pick
ucla great big
name something you might hurt yourself
right now oh lord
you know what i'm thinking uh you know
what i'm thinking a penis
shut up
nasty ass audience
you've been raping since the age of 13.
rapping
that makes more sense
you'd like to have some coffee green no
i just no i just see
[Applause]
no i said wow
in the indian traditional
tea park [ __ ] looks nice
china
do you want to do the awkward forest now
i mean it is about time no let's not do
the awkward you don't want to do the
awkward parts
it's so awkward
what do you want to do then i want to
feel comfortable
yeah come over here then
hey
my arms don't work but i got a lot of
spirit
this is a red kangaroo found in
australia and actually this is kind of a
bad time to bring a kangaroo on because
it's mating season so
whoa
so he's
he's trying to like
he's all right he's all right
and i i deliver music like it's art like
i feel like i'm a pop artist right and
cyborg i had to use the bathroom really
really bad and they didn't give me
enough time um
i just want to tell you that
so
it's blended so much into what you were
talking about
but i thought you had to use the
bathroom then
i have to use the bathroom really bad
right now okay entire interview yeah
that's okay uh here's more expressive
butter
and
see
and this next area you would think no
how could he look like this
and here you go there he is
may i say one thing yes
someone has a lot of time on their hands
no you've never seen friends have you
i've seen a lot of parts of it
but also you must meet people who are so
young and like they're watching for the
first time
my daughter watches it
well that that you would think that's
like a fun father-daughter activity
you're not all white are you all white
no you've got another thing in you
you got korean you're white
did you hear what he just said
that was the wildest comeback i ever
heard from
bro i go
i go you're not all white you got
another thing in you and he goes
but i'm lucky
when you fall
when you fall when you're older it's
different from falling when you're
younger like young when you young and
you fall
right
my life flashed before
[Applause]
i always had a big butt i can see mine
from the front like at certain moments
like i'll be in the mirror i'll be like
it's pretty cute in my opinion but thing
is like it's like a peekaboo to like
what's next so like once you see it from
the front like that's all cool but like
wait until you see it
like from the back because that is
really that's that's when it gets crazy
you guys always have to be in superhero
shape if you ever get a break do you
ever get like a month to just like get
massive
i try not to let it go too much you know
scarlet's always in superhero shape
don't let her tell you anything
otherwise that black widow suit slips on
and off pretty easily she tell people
that she's just ready that's what that
sounds like by the way what are you
gonna be do you think when you grow up a
farmer oh have you ever lived on a farm
yeah how do you milk a cow what's the
first thing you need to milk a cow a cow
actually your your name
is a mystery to me yeah
because it is spelt
s a o i r s e
which is a lot of vowels
it's it's four of the five vowels it
really is my first name alone what's the
worst butchering of it you've ever heard
i mean everything except for sercia so
i've never heard sarsha once uh sorcy
sarah's scarcity i've got skirting
yeah say her eyes the worst one i had
though and it's so amazing because it's
actually a name i was walking into an
airport and i had someone picking me up
and they had the
name card and i'm scanning everyone i
can't see my name can't see anywhere and
all of a sudden i see shelley ronan
[Laughter]
you're a sound guy just to show us what
the audio processor was he he set it up
for us on this microphone would you tell
me how to use it how would it would it
work if i i think if you talk directly
into it but if i speak it doesn't really
do anything right but if i sing it'll do
something to my voice is that right
you don't care you just have to go to
the bathroom
i was at the mall with my nephew
babysitting i'm just walking through the
mall and a woman i didn't know pulled up
a knee she goes is that your son i go no
it's my nephew and she she without any
hesitation she's he is adorable what's
your name you are so cute marcus when
you turn 18 i'm coming back for you
you're a little heartbreaker save him
for me
and she walked away went back to
shopping
i challenge any man in this room
any guy go to the mall just approach a
woman you don't know is that your niece
can i have a word with her please
wow when you turn 18 i'm coming back for
you
[Music]
i know
[Music]
i was i was the guy that was never
serious uh the most serious moments i
always made the funniest moments i got
along with everybody i was probably the
most popular kid in school because i was
funny um and i played basketball so
that's not nice
what just happened
that was so funny
i don't know brad that wasn't that
wasn't a joke no yes it is no no it's
gotta be you got to be being funny right
now i played varsity basketball like a
little league no no there was no little
league i was nine through 12 if you go
look it up kevin hart played varsity you
know see i could have chose basketball
but comedy chose me there was talks
there was talks about me going to the
nba i want you to google zion baptist
church it's a league i played in uh
there's a church league
if you if you go
if y'all go look up my stats in this
church league i averaged 17 6 and 5.
honestly uh mvp of the church league two
years in a row granted it was me and a
bunch of deacons
but but
but you was
i mean i like how many calories are in
the hunter spider is that so fattening
or is it quite scary i always go for the
low cal low calorie drug do you ever put
them in a sandwich like a croque
monsieur de la spider
little extra carbs you know you know
what we have right here right now what
we have a bear sandwich absolutely
jerry was there ever any doubt in your
mind that you would have any difficulty
wrestling
andy
not really no doubt at all you see i
don't i don't want to sit out here and
pretend that i'm friends with this guy
because i think he's a wimp
you see when i think when andy was born
his father wanted a boy and his mother
wanted a girl and they were both
satisfied
even you asked me last time i was on
your show if i if i was uh going to have
a lawsuit and i could have sued you i
could have sued you for everything
you're worth and i didn't because i'm
not that kind of a guy yeah you know
what uh what kind of a guy are you
no
you're not the kind of guy i'll just be
over here
we're going to do this here for station
identification get the hoses
[Applause]